بكره واحده تواصل هؤلاء الفتيات اللعب
قبلنا فريق اتحاد جد النسوي وهو احد الفرق
النسائيه الرياضيه القليله في المملكه
العربيه
السعوديه الكابتن لينا المعينه اسست هذا
الفريق منذ عشر سنوات وكان هدفها اعطاء
الفتيات فرصه لمزاوله رياضه كره السله
باحترافيه عاليه ففي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حيث تطبق التعاليم الاسلاميه لا
يسمح للمراه مارسه الرياضات المختلفه في
الاماكن العامه وفي هذه المدينه لا يوجد
ملاعب رياضيه عامه مخصصه للنساء وكذلك لا
تتوفر حصص الرياضه في مدارس الاناث
الحكوميه الحصص الرياضيه متوفره فقط في
المدارس الخاصه لذلك الفتاه التي تلتحق
بمدرسه خاصه تكون محظوظه بوجود الحصص
الرياضيه ولعب الرياضات المختلفه هدير
صدقه ذات 18 عاما تحلم باللعب بالالعاب
الاولمبيه يوما ما وبسبب التوجه المحافظ
السائد بالمملكه يصعب ارسال فرق النسويه
الى الاولمبياد والاتحادات الرياضيه الشيخ
عدنان باحارث الف كتابا بين من خلاله
ضوابط السلامه في ممارسه الفتيات للتربيه
الرياضيه ويقول الشيخ ان ارتداء الفتاه
للملابس الضيقه غير جائز ابدا وانه على
المراه ممارسه الرياضه في البيت فكيف لها
ان تخرج وتلعب الرياضه بين الرجال وهم
ينظرون اليها عوه على ان ذلك يتعرض مع
الدين من مختلف النواحي ولكن في المحكمه
اصرت النساء على ان الرياضه لا تتعرض مع
الاسلام الذي يشجع على ممارسه الرياضه
بحسب هؤلاء الفتيات انا شخصيا لا اعتقد
اننا نفعل شيئا خاطئا بل نحن نمارس رياضه
صحيه ومفيده للجسم والعقل المعينه ليس
لديها امل في ان يشارك فريقها بالالعاب
الاولمبيه في الوقت القريب فهن يلعبن
وينافسن على مستويات محليه
فقط قبل اربع سنوات كان من المحظور الحديث
في هذا الموضوع لذا اعتقد ان المجتمع
يتغير
ويتطور وكما تقول فالتغيير بطيء ولكنه
قادم لا
محاله